lors de la grande première mondiale du
film my soul ndjoli la berlinale se
multipliaient les autographes
le réalisateur philippe falardeau
s'amuser ferme mais après les fleurs il
ya eu le pot dès le lendemain matin
en certaines critiques sont plus sévères
que d'autres de guardian accorde une
étoile sur cinq est écrit que la
berlinale ne peut que cv maintenant un
dérailleur lui donne deux étoiles et
demie affirmant que le film n'a pas été
capable de réconcilier caricature et
réalisme le vaio russie et le hollywood
reporter ne sont pas plus délicat fait
les falardeau connais bien son cinéma
mais il ne lit pas les critiques je
pourrais sûrement écrire moi-même toutes
les critiques de ce film sans aucune
retenue et sans aucun cynisme
j'ai pas besoin de les lire une des
critiques du film est sans aucun doute
le jeu de la crise mme madray quoi les
ailes étaient convaincantes dans il
était une fois à hollywood elle l'est
beaucoup moins dans my sabine joliet en
entrevue elle affirme à son tour qu'elle
ne lit pas les critiques ce portrait de
femme amoureuse de littérature est à la
croisée des chemins
manager est loin d'être mauvais film
mais il n'est peut-être pas taillé sur
mesure pour des critiques de cinéma à la
recherche de petits bijoux
moi je pense la force du film c'est de
cesser de raconter une histoire qui
équipe qui ne se
qui ne reposent pas sur des artifices
dramatique ou des coups de théâtre
mais demandez faiblesse du film c'est
que peut-être que le film promet
beaucoup attentes en termes émotif et
que tout le monde s'y retrouve
ce n'est pas la première ni la dernière
fois qu'un film présenté en ouverture de
la berlinale et critiquer ainsi car le
pari est toujours audacieux et risqué
l'équipe de marseille en juillet doit
maintenant trouver un distributeur
américain pourrait être présenté en
salle ou encore un service de télévision
en continu comme netflix ici louis
philippe ouimet radio-canada berlin